le commissaire européen michel barnier
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes avec nous alors qu'une lutte est
engagée elle met aux prises des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de l'union qui
à la tête de la commission de bruxelles
ça ne va pas de soi apparemment malgré
le résultat de l'élection parlement
européen au risque donc de renforcer
l'image de
démocratie hors sol que renvoie trop
souvent l'union européenne comme vous
l'écrivez d'ailleurs dans ce livre
michel barny se reposer ou être libre
l'europe la france dans l'union les
réformes qui s'imposent à l'une et à
l'autre nous allons en parler donc au
cours de ce prof par trois que vous
propose public sénat avec l' agence
france presse avec perrine tarneaud donc
et guillaume daudin en partenariat
toujours comme chaque semaine avec
dailymotion d'abord bien sûr la bataille
de la succession de josé manuel barroso
avec ce front anti juncker et l'ancien
premier ministre luxembourgeois dont le
parti votre parti est arrivé vainqueur
en tête un des élections européennes
alors est-ce qu'on se dirige vers un
déni de démocratie
puis un processus qui est engagée c'est
jamais simple
sauf que cette fois ci il ya eu quelque
chose de nouveau que nous avons voulu
les différents partis politiques le
parti populaire européen qui regroupe
tous les partis de centre droit j'en
suis l'un des vice-présidents le parti
socialistes et libéraux les verts et
d'autres encore pour dire aux citoyens
vous allez également participer au choix
du présent de la commission en plus des
liens répété pendant la campagne vient
on attend donc le résultat a eu lieu le
parti populaire est arrivée en tête très
clairement en tête ont je crois dans le
groupe parlementaire 31 sièges de plus
que le second parti le parti socialiste
européen est donc clairement c'est la
chose que je peux vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est grossier
papa pas beaucoup plus le parti
populaire européen et son animateur que
nous ont présentés comme tels jean
claude juncker ont la légitimité pour
être le pivot de la future grande
majorité de projet qui doit se
construire au parlement et ça descend
jean-claude une clause pour être présent
la commission doit il doit d'être nommé
c'est le choix maintenant des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement puisque c'est
leur responsabilité
il faut respecter les traités et c'est
le choix du parlement européen je ne
peux pas dire quelle sera l'issue de ces
discussions mais c'est le processus qui
est tendu la jambe et le processus il
est entravée aujourd'hui c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire par le premier
ministre britannique david cameron qui
fait barrage et alors il faut leur
concept est encore aujourd'hui avec une
angela merkel que plutôt ambigu
puisqu'elle lui fait les yeux doux au
premier ministre britannique
non madame merkel que je connais bien
elle est soucieuse comme je le suis moi
même que tout le monde reste à bord que
le royaume uni qui est un des très
grands pays de l'union européenne qui
est tellement importante pour le marché
du qui attachent d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'importance au marché unique et qui est
aussi un élément clé un acteur clef
d'une future politique étrangère
européenne une future politique de
défense européenne reste bien dans
l'union à vous savez bien regarder les
résultats pourraient du mini qu'il y à
de fortes tentations le parti du clip
est arrivé en tête de de séparation et
donc moi je pense que si on se sépare et
ce sera un affaiblissement pour tout le
monde pour qu'il faut faire attention à
sable en faut faire attention faut aller
vers un compromis qui pourrait exclure
jean claude juncker on vous comprend je
vous écoute je vous écoute et l'épargné
dans la balance il y a la grande
bretagne qui reste dans l'union ou
juncker présidera la commission a entre
les deux choix on veut comprendre je
vous il faut retenir la grande rejoint
j'ai dit clairement mon souhait est que
je te d'une cure soit choisi et je suis
loyal depuis le premier jour avec lui ce
jour là je me souviens précisément
puisque j'étais en compétition avec lui
au sein du parti populaire européen et
un débat qui avait un vote démocratique
et secret je fais 40 % des voix il a
fait 60 % depuis ce jour là je le
soutiens avant l'élection le journal x
ans et depuis l'élection je ne changerai
pas de ligne qui est celle de la loyauté
je dis simplement que jean claude
juncker présente la commission le
parlement européen les autres
commissaires doivent être attentifs à
une question qui n'est pas négligeable
qui est celle de l'unité du marché
unique et de la présence dont nous avons
besoin de rendre deux royaumes mais ce
que votre loyauté monsieur juncker vous
empêche demain d'être vous pour la
commission pour la présidence de la
commission le candidat de compromis mais
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas la question
mais moi je vous réponds que je ne veux
pas répondre à cette question parce que
je suis dans une vie c'est la solution
nous sommes dans un processus où
normalement jean claude juncker à cette
légitimité le parti populaire européen
lui même pourrait payer un blocage sur
sa personne par exemple à vide comme on
dit c'est un homme du passé pouvez me
poser quatre fois la question à vous
l'avez déjà fait trois fois je ne
voudrais pas une autre réponse et
j'aimerais bien que plutôt que de parler
des personnes on parle quand on parle du
royaume uni sa présence des raisons de
sa présence ce qu'il faudrait faire
comme signe aux citoyens britanniques et
des français sur l'axé bureaucratie
bruxelles qui s'occupe de tout rien de
vrai qu est-ce qu assurer nouvelles on
impose comme un oui mais j'aimerais bien
qu'on en vienne à ça comme enfermé de
réglementation au moins une bureaucratie
à bruxelles épouse de poule à bout vous
avez personnellement - pas très bonne
presse non plus à londres parce que vous
avez pris des mesures pour une plus
grande régulation financière dans
l'union dans vos fonctions à bruxelles
j'ai pris ces mesures avec le soutien du
jour mais ça ça peut pas forcément la
city quand même j'ai fait tout cela avec
la city par contre elle et sans elle
qu'est ce que ça voudrait dire
d'ailleurs de faire une régulation
financière après cette crise terrible
dont on n'a pas fini de payer les
conséquences il ya tellement de gens qui
souffrent en europe contre les anglais
contre la city qui est la principale
place financière donc j'ai fait c'était
mon choix toutes ces régulations avec la
city ont passé l'essentiel au gré des
circonstances des événements qu'on
évoque sur lesquels vous ne voulez pas
vous étendre à michel barnier mais enfin
si au gré des circonstances vous re
redevenir un candidat vous devenez un
candidat crédible pour succéder à
monsieur barroso est ce que vous
craignez que françois hollande se pose
avoue
franchement posez lui la question c'est
à lui de répondre c'est sa
responsabilité de nommer le commissaire
français comme c'était le cas de ses
prédécesseurs il le fera en tenant
compte de l'intérêt de l'europe et de la
place de la france dans l'europe
franchement je ne vais pas répondre à
ces messages et en sang parce que vous
ne vous ont toutes dernières questions
mais c'est celle que je vous ai posé
d'emblée est ce que vous craignez que eh
bien on soit face à un déni de
démocratie en europe 2 à la fin du mois
de juin avec la nomination le choix du
successeur de josé manuel barroso si ça
ne correspond pas à ce qu'on a à dire
aux électeurs pendant toute la campagne
et alors que même les opposants de
gauche de votre parti disent ces unions
coeur et qui arrive en tête c'est lui
qu'il faut choisir oui parce qu'il
réunit démocratie oui ou non je ne
souhaite pas que ce soit le cas je
souhaite franchement est un risque qui
que je souhaite franchement que les deux
institutions qui doivent décider le
conseil européen qui doit faire une
proposition comme le dit le traité en
tenant compte du résultat des élections
et le parlement qui doit donner son
investiture au moins par 3 175 voix se
mettent d'accord pour choisir un
candidat conformément au vote des
citoyens alors pour moi ce candidat
devrait être gentil d'une clan voilà ce
que je peux vous dire je peux pas dire
autre chose ce qui me paraît plus
important quand on regarde comment les
français notamment voté ou plutôt
pourquoi beaucoup d'entre 60 % n'ont pas
voté c'est qu'on parle des politiques et
changer alors vous avez de thein sein
devrait vous intéresser à saré bas nous
sommes passionnés parfois réservé aux
propositions personnelles il ya toute
une série dans tous les domaines michel
berger même fait un petit bouquin avant
les élections et qui vaut 11 euros 50 a
pris citoyens les droits de ce livre à
une association qui s'occupe d'haïti
dont ont dû poser présidente et donc
j'ai fait ce petit bouquin pour
participer au débat d'idées parce que ce
qui intéresse les gens de là des hommes
des femmes des postes c'est qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour pour tirer les leçons de
la crise qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
entendre les citoyens et répondent au
canada justement vous avez vous des
solutions que vous préconisez vous en
avez assez de voir l'union a présenté
comme le bouc émissaire de tous les maux
de l'europe et de la france en
particulier françois hollande a réagi en
disant que l'europe était illisible
incompréhensible pour les citoyens vous
êtes d'accord là elle est bien sûr
difficile à comprendre les complexes
très elle est d'autant plus complexe et
illisible qu'on n'explique pas oui donc
il faut que les acteurs politiques
présents la république qui le fait les
lignes et qu'ils ne font pas assez les
dépôts européenne un problème de
pédagogie le chef de l'état dit aussi il
faut arrêter
l'europe s'occupe de tout attendez celle
de choses différentes que l'europe soit
illisibles parce qu'elle est complexe
c'est clair on pourrait mettre plus de
simplicité et d'unité j'ai proposé dans
mon livre qui un jour un président de
l'union européenne et qui cumulerait y
aura une personne au lieu de deux les
fonctions de la commission prétendu
conseillera l'impératif de démocratie
alors j'ai proposé qu'il y ait une plus
grande lisibilité au titre de la sphère
financière et économique en ayant un
ministre européen des finances après la
complexité je prends une minute pour
l'expliquer elle est un peu la condition
d'une europe unie qui n'est pas uniforme
nous ne sommes pas un état fédéral on
veut pas être en état ferrat il n'y a
pas un peuple européen il n'y a pas une
nation européenne il ya 28 nations 28
peuple 28 états qu'ils fusionnent pas
mais qui mutualisent une partie de leur
destin leur souveraineté et de leur
politique pour être plus forts et pour
être respecté dans le monde ça peut pas
être simple si c'est simple c'est
uniforme donc il faut expliquer à ceux
qui nous écoutent que la complexité de
bruxelles la commission européenne et
que ses 28 personnes qui constituent une
sorte de premiers ministres européens
tous ensemble le conseil des ministres
la chambre d etat parlement européen qui
la change rien c'est forcément complexes
il fait le temps de la campagne pour ça
oui c'était jusqu'au 25 mai cette
campagne qui doit durer trois petites
semaines vous rattraper pas en propre
semaines d'une campagne qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas été qui était très
hexagonale au lendemain des élections
municipales 30 ans de silence et voilà
pourquoi je suis content de vous parler
aujourd'hui après la après l'élection
parce que c'est maintenant le temps du
deuil mais est-ce qu'il faut réduire les
compétences de l'union ça c'est une
mesure concrète j'ai proposé dans le
cadre de mon débat au sein du récit
peuple et non pas une idée que je crois
juste pour l'avenir c'est ce qu'on
appellerait en anglais lui open added
value review c'était une révision des
compétences et des politiques en partant
de leurs intérêts de leur valeur ajoutée
européenne est-ce que telle compétence
européenne dans le traité speitel
politique a encore ou n'a pas encore
pourrait avoir ou à trop ou n'a pas de
valeur ajoutée et en réviser en soit la
somme de compétences face à l'europe
passoire on n'a aucune réponse spago à
la question britannique c'est aussi une
question aux français qui sont très
nombreux se poser des questions sur est
ce que l'europe ne s'occupe pas trop de
tout et de n'importe quoi cette fuite en
avant
pas de frontières pas de limite je pense
que cette révision que j'ai proposée
serait tabou outinord pas de route hier
avec un vrai débat punaise face à
l'europe passoire souvent dénoncé comme
tel en tous les cas ce qu'il faut
suspendre schengen il faut pas suspendre
schengen il faut appliquer et renforce
schengen comment vous imaginez par
rapport aux flux de ces immigrés est
souvent
utilisé d'ailleurs par des trafiquants
par des mafias qui utilisent la pauvreté
et la misère on le voit avec ces bateaux
comment vous imaginez de répondre chacun
chez soi chacun pour soi ça laissait
malte chypre la grèce l'italie l'espagne
tout seul c'est une question européenne
il faut pas suspendu il faut appliquer
renforcer sa ce qu'avait proposé nicolas
sarkozy ya vu que je laisse le temps et
on a commencé il avait déjà proposé il
ya qu un seul quand nous avons appliqué
une première alors qu'il avait souhaitée
et moi je souhaite qu'on applique
schengen on peut appeler ça schengen
deux très bien schengen trois matches et
dimensions en tous les cas on peut
passer ses ordres il faut gérer en
commun new frontier créer un corps de
gardes frontières commun créer une force
européenne je le dis dans mon bouquin
une force européenne de protection
civile pour être capable pas seulement
dans le cas de ces malheureux qui sont
dans des bateaux mais dans le cas de
catastrophes naturels d'inondation une
catastrophe nucléaire de du nahd quatre
industriels vers son ami être capable
répondre ensemble plus d'argent qu'un
pur soit renforcer schengen n'est pas le
suspense est votre point de vue paris
est elle fondée a menacé washington de
en parle encore de frontières de
suspendre les négociations qui sont
engagées sur le très controversé traité
transatlantique et tout cela pour
répondre à la menace d'amendés record
qui qui qui pourraient viser la bbc
paribas bon j'ai une réponse un peu plus
générales vous rêvez déjà fait quand il
va faire ce nom de demain avec
l'espionnage américain qui ne doit pas
se faire qu il ne devrait pas se faire
entre alliés et entre amis j'ai quand on
a des problèmes comme ça avec des alliés
c'est une raison de plus pour discuter
pas con pas de se tourner le dos je
serais tenté de dire la même chose
maintenant c'est cette affaire de la bnp
prix c'est à cause de cela oui que de
telle ou telle idée a été émise moi je
voudrais très prudent cette affaire ne
serait pas justice américaine elle est
très complexe je compte tenu de
l'ampleur de la bnp et des risques je
comprends que les autres étaient
françaises suivent ça attentivement dans
les autorités européennes aussi nous
nous suivons très attentivement cette
situation la seule chose que je peux
dire dans le respect de l'indépendance
de justice américaine c'est que nous
souhaitons que c'est donc soit traité
comme tous les autres acteurs manière
équitable et objective d'accord et on y
voit des amendes demandées quand même je
ne connais pas le détail de cette
affaire j'ai mes qualités je souhaite
que cette affaire soit traitée de
manière cette banque de manière
équitable et objectifs ça vous le
demander aux états unis alors guillaume
daudin de l'agencé france presse va nous
rejoindre maintenant on va vous
interrogez ja barnier sur la france
malade de l'europe bien sûr avec ses
piètres performances économiques et puis
la place de numéro un qui est occupé
désormais à l'issue de ce scrutin
européen par le front national d'abord
donc le rappel de quelques données clés
par marie brémaud
la france rappelé à l'ordre par
bruxelles c'était il ya trois mois la
commission européenne ce alertait des
dérapages budgétaires
avec des prévisions de déficit à 4% du
produit intérieur brut paris reste bien
loin de l'objectif fixé à 3,6 pour cent
pour 2014 dans le cas français
on reste sur les objectifs mais souvent
on demande une dérogation pour ce qui
est des échéances aujourd'hui la france
est devenue champ du tout un problème
pour l'europe un problème pour elle même
d'abord il est vrai que la france
accumule les mauvais résultats et ce
depuis plusieurs années en matière de
déficit en matière de croissance en
matière de compétitivité la france entre
dans le peloton de queue de l'union
européenne comment se fait-il que c'est
en france que le taux d'impôt sur les
bénéfices des sociétés est le plus élevé
38 % alors que d'autres pays sont entre
15 et 20% comment se fait-il que ce soit
en france que les prélèvements sur les
salaires les contributions sociales sont
les plus élevés de tous les pays de
l'union européenne etc ainsi on est
disqualifié en quelque sorte la
compétitivité du travail en france mais
la france est elle un pays réformable à
l'heure où ses voisins du sud comme
l'espagne l'italie ou le portugal mais
ton oeuvre des mesures drastique et
impopulaires paris apparaît bien souvent
réfractaires au changement c'est un pays
qui est vu sommes en difficulté par les
autres et quand je dis en difficulté
cette difficulté à s'extraire un peu du
passé dans le fond le problème de la
france c'est ça c'est cette difficulté à
quitter un peu la nostalgie
des trente glorieuses et devenir un pays
qui
se modernise y compris en touchant en
touchant à ski la plus fondamentale
c'est à dire aussi en réformant le
social mais avec le pacte de
responsabilité
le gouvernement français semble emprunté
le bon chemin bruxelles s'en félicite
mais maintient la pression sur paris
quant à son application
voilà guillaume daudin de la fp est avec
nous michèle bernier aux questions des
commissaires européens sur la france
le pacte de responsabilité sur les rails
mais ce matin était publié un appel
d'une centaine de députés ps avec des
contre propositions de projet de loi de
finances rectificative donc ils
demandent moins d'argent pour les
entreprises et en étant plus d'argent
pour le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
l'investissement public où les emplois
plus employé dès qu'est ce que vous
dites au gouvernement vous leur dites de
tenir bon ou d'écouter les frondeurs
mais d'écouter franchement ne me
demandez pas comme commissaire pas de
venir me mais les relations entre la
majorité telle ou telle partie du groupe
socialiste et le gouvernement sur les
réformes c'est pas tout à fait la
question je je je pense que le moment où
nous sommes à un moment de vérité et où
il va falloir que tout le monde fasse
preuve de courage politique les députés
socialistes le gouvernement qui me
paraît aller dans la bonne direction et
peut-être aussi si vous me permettez de
vous dire l'opposition parce que s'il ya
des mesures en application du plan valls
qui vont dans la bonne direction je
pense que l'opposition devrait aller
voter pas ça m'est arrivé des députés
d'opposition dans france et de voter des
mesures proposées par le gouvernement et
réciproquement exemple le pâté de
responsabilité vous voulez voter
voteriez il y à des mesures il faut voir
le contenu s'agissant de la baisse des
charges des impôts sur les entreprises
qui sont tellement pénalisé qu'elle ne
bouge plus e il faut libérer des voix
jeune j'ai été élu pendant 17 ans d'un
conseil général en savoie je tiens
toujours à grenoble rencontrer des chefs
d'entreprise dans le code domaine de
l'innovation une énergie contenue il ya
une formidable capacité d'initiative
dans ce pays d'innovation
d'investissement mais qui contenu qui
est bloqué il faut libérer et c'est pour
ça que je pense de tout à l'heure on
parlait d
''j'ai que si on libère en appliquant
les mesures de monsieur valls sans doute
en allant plus loin d'ailleurs on libère
cette capacité là on va retrouver la
cour si je comprends bien ce que vous
dites françois hollande a évolué depuis
le début de son quinquennat il va plutôt
dans le bon sens c'est ça vous dit il je
dis simplement qu'il a lui-même toujours
dit qu'il respecterait les fameux
critères de déficit qui ça ne vient pas
fait pour faire plaisir à bruxelles
franchement bien sûr il ya bien comme
que j'en dirais un règlement de
copropriété de la zone euro on n'a pas
d'ailleurs suffisamment respectée dans
le passé c'est pour ça qu'on a été dans
cette crise en plus de la crise
financière il faut respecter ce
règlement de copropriété vis-à-vis des
autres mais c'est pas pour faire plaisir
à bruxelles ses vis-à-vis des jeunes
français qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
continuer à tirer des chèques en blanc
en bois sur les générations futures les
impôts dont les les emprunts
d'aujourd'hui les dettes certains disent
au groupe socialiste faisait encore plus
de dette ont fait pas de la croissance
avec des dettes les dettes d'aujourd'hui
ce sont des impôts pour deux pour nos
enfants ça suffit vous savez combien on
paye de charge de la dette le service de
la dette coûte 46 milliards chaque année
au budget de la france plus que le
budget de l'éducation nationale c'est
pas normal mais certains reprochent un
peu à la commission européenne que
finalement il n'y aurait qu'une seule
voie ça serait la réduction des dépenses
publiques pour être poli l'austérité
pour c'est pas la même chose et on peut
parler d'austérité dans certains pays et
sans doute at-elle été trop brutale et
j'ai plaidé en a même pour qu'on
différencie les niveaux des efforts dans
le temps et pour certains pays nous
faisons ça me permet à culpa par rapport
à ce qui était décidé pour l'europe du
sud probablement dans certains pays le
niveau des efforts a été trop brutale
mais nous nous avons compris cela est
maintenant différent c'est vers ces pays
font de très gros efforts et tous sont
en train de sortir de 2,2 de la plus
grande difficulté y compris la grèce le
portugal l'espagne sont intenses à la
fois non franchement c'est la bonne
gestion vis-à-vis des générations
futures oh la la france est pleine de
rhumatismes elle est trop conservatrice
elle est trop centralisée il faut
libérer ce pays et regarder pourquoi ça
marche mieux chez les autres qui sont
également dans la zone euro pourquoi ça
marche mieux en allemagne je dis pas
qu'il faut tout copier mais en allemagne
vous avez des entreprises
l'entrepreneuriat régional qui est
soutenu par les banques et familiale
vous avez une culture de stabilité
budgétaire ont fait des dépenses ont
fait des ans promet pour l'avenir pas
pour payer le fonctionnement on a le
dialogue social notre pays franchement
est incapable na na na pas c'est le
modèle allemand qui est peut-être la
bonne voie je pense qu'il y a il compris
nos domaines de la formation de
l'alternance de bonnes idées à prendre
chez les autres y compris dans les pays
nordiques mais vous avez commencé une
sorte de mea culpa et souvent dans cette
troïka donc union européenne banque
centrale et commission européenne banque
centrale et est fondée terrain
international on a dit que la bbl la
commission européenne était un peu les
ayatollahs l'austérité c'était ce qui
était le plus engagé dans la voie de
l'austérité je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
des gens plus durs que d'autres aient eu
des décisions prises à trois et
probablement de dans l'urgence le dos au
mur au début de cette crise qui était
absolument inouïe parce que je rappelle
que la crise financière qui est venu des
états unis du comportement irresponsable
de certaines banquier de certaines
banques qui sont trop tout permis plutôt
à qui on avait tout permis à force de
déréguler est venu impacter une europe
qui était faible jacques delors
d'ailleurs dit lui même on peut pas voir
l'union monétaire et la désunion
économique et plus en plus la désunion
économique et la crise financière on
avait des pays qui étaient noyés sous
les dettes comme la grèce et d'autres
donc on apprendre le mois dans l'urgence
pour trouver le bon chemin pour en
sortir
peut-être eu des problèmes d'ajustement
de niveau 2 les formulaires en jeu nous
sommes nous sommes sur la bonne foi je
vous rappelle la nécessité des efforts
budgétaires mais certains économistes
disent que leurs complexes par exemple
de 1% la dépense publique et bien il ya
une baisse de croissance de 1%
équivalente alors il ya aussi des
risques ça dépend où vous fait peser la
baisse à vous ça dépend où il ya
naturellement vous des mauvaises bien
sûr il ya de bonnes et de mauvaises
dettes il ya rien endettement qui peut
être comme l'avait fait à l'époque
françois fillon sur les dépenses
d'avenir la recherche l'investissement
et le gouvernement actuel fait aussi de
deux de bons investissements
il ya des investissements qui préparent
l'avenir mais faire payer le
fonctionnement de la france
d'aujourd'hui
papa par deux par des impôts sur nos
enfants je trouve que c'est pas mal
est un paumé certains partis en france
ont mis en cause la question de l'euro
ils ont dit en france à cause de l'euro
sur lequel on n'a pas vraiment de
pouvoir de décision on est obligé de
faire de la dévaluation salariale pour
être compétitif j'imagine que vous
pensez que c'est pas forcément le
problème le pourquoi ça se passe pas
comme ça chez les autres dans la zone
euro pourquoi l'allemagne n'a pas le
même problème c'est bien la preuve que
c'est pas l'euro l'euro probablement
être un peu fort et d'ailleurs vous avez
vu le président la banque centrale
européenne ne se draguer son équipe
prend des mesures très fortes pour pour
répondre à ce risque qui n'est pas
encore là mais qui peut se produire de
déflation et moi je fais confiance à la
banque centrale européenne qui joue son
rôle et qui jeu qui le joue bien mais
regardez dans la zone euro regardez d'où
vient notre déficit commercial il est
dans la zone euro où ils ont la même
monnaie c'est bien que ce n'est pas le
problème la monnaie le problème c'est
d'autres nombre de compétitivité et
alors c'est parti vous répondra
peut-être justement le problème
justement c'est pas l'euro pour tous
mais en tout cas l'euro pour la france
est au niveau de la france peut-être que
il faudrait en sortir non il faut pas en
sortir il faut il faut pas se cacher
sous la table et faire la politique de
l'autruche parce qu'on on aura des
problèmes encore plus grave à régler et
on sera tous seuls pour les régler il
faut faire fonctionner leurs eaux faire
confiance à la banque centrale pour
qu'ils aient le bon niveau se préserver
des dévaluations entre nous vous vous
imaginez qu'on revienne aux dévaluations
dans la même zone européenne
comme cette magique les j'étais présent
de la savoie pendant 17 ans j'ai vu le
les conséquences des dévaluation de la
lire italienne juste de l'autre côté de
la montagne d'un seul coup des centaines
d'emplois étaient détruites pas par la
dévaluation tanks et on a enfin de la
stabilité il faut gérer l'euro avec une
économie coordonnées on est en train de
le faire et puis il faut réformer la
france il faut diminuer les charges
qu'il faut du mulet impôts il faut faire
de la stabilité le fiscal et
administratif et 100 d'entre vous amuser
donc au courage politique les dirigeants
l'opposition et puis les français
également vous êtes de passage avec nous
aujourd'hui à paris entre bruxelles
etats-unis et vous vous êtes de passage
à paris alors qu'il ya une mobilisation
des chauffeurs de taxi des cheminots des
intermittents du spectacle qui défendent
leur statut quand vous voyez ça que vous
avez envie de rire jeudi que le
gouvernement je vais pas me prononcer
sur telle ou telle réforme dont je n'ai
pas la responsabilité je vois bien qu'il
est difficile de réformer la france mais
il faut que le gouvernement et de la
ténacité et du courage et c'est le
moment et ça explique aussi peut-être
faiblesse de la france c'est cette
absence de dialogue social de dialogue
politique et l'absence de débat
regardez-la la campagne européenne dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure elle était
tellement hexagonal est tellement courte
on sait si mal si peu parlé de l'europe
le dialogue social dans l'entreprise
dans les branches dans le pays voilà une
des clés du succès allemand aussi on a
parlé de ses difficultés de la france
une amende parfois on entend la france
est donc l'homme malade de l'union
européenne et puis il ya eu le résultat
des du dernier scrutin et le fn a été
placé en tête en france qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce score c'est qu'il
faudrait je pense pas que la france soit
l'homme malade a des faiblesses elle a
des faiblesses je viens de les dire
elles sont sérieuses elles sont graves
il faut redresser ce pays et le faire
par le dialogue social et avec tous les
partenaires mais je pense que c'est
possible on a paru important tous les
cas on a une faiblesse et c'est la
faiblesse de la france et la faiblesse
de l'europe c'est pour ça que j'ai eu
une leçon de cette crise et que le
problème de l'un devient très vite le
prem de tout le monde donc il faut
corriger et c'est pas les autres qui
vont venir fall trail peu non c'est nous
qui devrons le faire alors que le score
du voilà du front national aux émotions
pas été surpris parce que quand on parle
si peu si mal de l'europe pendant vingt
ou trente ans quand il ya tant de
difficultés tant de peur qu'on dise
acerbe le la peur des autres
l'immigration qui est mal contrôlé quand
il ya parfois des déceptions l'égard des
personnes politiques quand il ya
tellement de chômage ait des gens qui
souffrent on peut on l'a vu dans les
banlieues et parfois dans les milieux
ruraux voudrait toujours des gens pour
pour utiliser ça pour exploiter sa mère
pour proposer mans il ya eu cette
dernière sortie de jean marie le pen ce
week-end il a parlé de la fournée au
sujet de l'artiste patrick bruel est ce
que vous pensez que il a sa place au
parlement européen il ya des bus des
appels par le biais jégo il a été élu et
là tu relances c'est pas très neuf de la
part de sur le pen que ces dérapages si
je puis dire c'est des vrais racistes ou
antisémites que je trouve absolument
insupportable s'il ne respecte pas la
loi il faut que la loi il ne sera
condamné au terme de la loi mais je
trouve qu'il ya dans ce pays tellement
de tension tellement de violence que le
rôle des hommes politiques quels qu'ils
soient ces taux ne pas rajouter un faux
pas de bras pas être déchu de s'ils ne
respectent pas la loi qui luttent qui
condamne l'antisémitisme et la
xénophobie
il doit être condamné mais c'est elle
c'est un début des parties prenantes de
se retourner contre lui et donc en
france et une certaine vague
souverainiste on va dire en tout cas d
un appel a déjà été condamnée d'ailleurs
comme vous le savez il ya un appel à
plus de souverainisme et par l'ombre un
dossier très précis le dossier alsthom
arnaud montebourg a pris un décret pour
élargir les secteurs réservés de
l'économie française préservé par dans
l'économie française si vous pensez
qu'il a pris la bonne décision que du
point de vue de la commission moi je
peux pas reprocher au gouvernement de
vouloir contrôler savoir qui achète quoi
en france d'ailleurs les allemands les
anglais ont des dispositifs comparables
a déjà dit ça mais aussi américains
aussi et déjà dispositifs qui existent
en france que le décret de monsieur
l'eau ce qui élargit le gouvernement
actuel nous sommes en train de regarder
s'il est conforme au traité
après la question de la politique
industrielle c'est pas le dos au mur en
urgence
lorsqu'il admet entreprises comme alstom
est en difficulté qu'il faut se demander
s'il doit être associés à general
electric ou à siemens moi je plaide pour
qu'on ait une véritable politique
industrielle et dans mon livre il ya
tout un chapelet de soulager tout un
chapitre pourquoi parce que la question
c'est de la liberté des européens comme
au reste libre comme un souverain comme
on reste indépendant dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui face au chili aux
allemands de siemens ne s'impose pas
forcément quoi il faut prendre la
meilleure politique la meilleure
solution industrielle américaine mais
encore une fois il faut que les
ministres de l'industrie des plusieurs
pays notamment français allemand les
industriels eux mêmes se mettent autour
de la table et voit quels sont les
secteurs stratégiques
les technologies clés qu'il faut
préserver c'est pas de protectionnisme
qui nous permettra de le faire la bonne
protection c'est pas de protectionniste
la bonne protection c'est
l'investissement c'est la recherche est
ce que les eaux grasses et n'aurait pas
pu justement investir dans alstom pour
essayer de le sortir de ce mauvais les
peut-être qu'ils avaient imaginé en s'y
prenant un peu plus tôt une autre
solution plus européenne avec des
partenaires mais ça ça se réfléchit pas
le dos au mur dans l'urgence s'alléger
puisqu'on parle la liberté européen j'ai
un tableau que je montre souvent à ce
qui m'interroge qui est un tableau
d'ailleurs publié par monsieur cameron
je sais pas si on le voit normalement
ils montrent tous les dix ans à partir
de maintenant les 4 les 10 pays les plus
importants du monde il ya quatre pays
européens en jaune parmi les 10
puissance du monde aujourd'hui seulement
quatre sur 28 pays et tous les dix ans
il y en a un qui est éjecté du tableau
mais quand est ce qu'on espère et on
disparaît en 2008 en 2050 pardon en 2050
laganière colonnes alors logé à 8 y a
plus un seul pays européens la suisse et
la corée par n'y sont pas et pourtant
c'est des économies performantes elles
ne sont pas encore mais vous avez la
chine l'inde les états unis nous si on
veut rester dans le tableau si on veut
rester à la table de ceux qui décident
plutôt que de subir et de regarder il
faut être ensemble c'est pour ça que la
liberté industrielle la liberté
numérique la liberté en termes de
d'énergie la dépendance énergétique la
défense sont des sujets ou jour notre
volonté où il faut ensemble merci
guillaume une petite question là david
cameron annoncé que l'union allait
s'attaquer aux abus de la liberté de
mouvement dans l'europe il dit ça contre
ceux qui perçoivent indûment c'est son
mot
les allocations des systèmes de
protection selon les pays vous êtes
d'accord avec cette démarche je pense
que les lois européennes qui encadre
cette les abus des libertés oui il ya
des lois européennes notamment la loi
sur le détachement des travailleurs la
liberté de circulation sont encadrés par
des textes il faut que ces textes
respectifs et ça ils seront tournés ces
textes aussi ça que monsieur cameron
venir en raison par exemple prenons la
question de détachement des travailleurs
vous avez une loi qui est utile qui
permet de lire à des centaines de
milliers de français d'aller travailler
dans votre pays européens il faut que
cette loi soit respectée que ce ne soit
pas synonyme de dumping d'entreprises
qui la détourne soit condamné il n'y a
pas de complaisance à voir la cure gens
allaient perrine tarneaud arrive
maintenant on va évoquer vos ambitions
européennes nationales aussi
les régionales peut-être aussi vous
allez nous dire ça dans un instant et
pour françois hollande dans tous les cas
votre succession à bruxelles pourrait
être un casse tête sauf à penser qu'ils
s'amusent a encouragé plusieurs
ambitions rivales samia de sheer
son mandat ni pas encore achevé mais
déjà la bataille pour sa succession est
engagé après cinq ans au poste de
commissaire européen pour la france à
michel barnier quittera son poste en
novembre
d'ici quelques semaines françois
hollande proposera donc au conseil
européen le candidat de son choix parmi
les socialistes plusieurs personnalités
ont déjà annoncé être intéressé par le
poste mais on cite surtout deux noms la
députée elisabeth guigou forte de son
expérience européenne face à pierre
moscovici qui semble très confiant pour
ne pas vous cacher un secret c'est
quelque chose dont nous parlions déjà
avec françois hollande depuis plusieurs
mois avant même ce remaniement moi je
vois ça non pas comme un lot de
consolation mais comme un projet comme
quelque chose qui est pour moi une façon
de poursuivre une action publique moins
médiatique la députée européenne
pervenche berès est elle aussi dans la
course
enfin il se murmure que jean marc
ayrault vre devenu député après son
passage à matignon se verrait bien lui
aussi à bruxelles je pense que c'est une
candidature un peu fantaisistes même si
effectivement et par l'allemand il n'a
pas du tout un passé de européens malgré
tout les commissaires qu'on a envoyé à
bruxelles a en tout cas michel barnier
il avait un vrai passé d'européens il
est il avait manifesté son intérêt
pierre moscovici a manifesté son intérêt
alors à bruxelles on n'attend pas
forcément pierre moscovici parce que il
avait une réputation de dilettante
on se dit que le jeudi soir et ont envie
de rentrer chez lui et de pas forcément
s'investir énormément contrairement par
exemple à une pervenche berès mais pour
l'instant personne ne se risque à
avancer le nom d'un réel favori françois
hollande a la réputation de décider seul
et au dernier moment son choix est
d'autant plus compliquée que la france
est aujourd'hui affaiblie face à
bruxelles nous sommes à la veille et
bien de subir des
condamnations voir au delà des
remontrances des pénalités de la part de
la commission européenne pour non
respect de nos engagements financiers de
quatre noms que vous venez de me citer
bas ils sont directement liées justement
à l'état
aujourd'hui de déficit économique je
dirais crucial de notre pays autre
inconnue le portefeuille qui reviendra à
la france pierre moscovici viserait un
poste économique tandis qu'elisabeth
guigou se verrait bien en chef de la
diplomatie européenne
ah bah écoutez votre place beaucoup
demandent
toujours commissaire leur père est
quelqu'un qui franchement je trouve ce
débat ap ce réaliste mais mais nous
sommes enchantés
mission nous sommes un j'ai rarement vu
dans le passé que les gens faisaient
campagne dont ça pour devenir
commissaire européen mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que nous sommes en fonction
jusqu'au mois d'octobre et ce temps doit
être utile c'est un temps de travail moi
j'ai pas de texte que le parlement qui
vient d'être renouvelée va à nouveau
examinée dès le mois de juillet sur la
régulation financière sur le contrôle
des balancements à partir plus tôt non
plus
jusqu'au bout j'ai super quad ambition
de se manifester alors je vais je donc
franchement c'est bien manifesté son
intérêt notre aviation a touché
et je suis encouragé à parler encore
plus d'europe ce que je sais que c'est
pas à moi qu'il faut demander de faire
des commentaires bien sûr mais
j'aimerais 7 me dire quel est le
portrait robot idéal futur comme ça vous
mettez des conditions dans votre livre
bon pour le poste les posteurs comme ça
à voiron une expérience européenne oui
oui il faut avoir une conviction bonjour
mandat il faut être une conviction et de
compétences il faut être respecté par
les autres et puis il faut être aussi
patriote et européen parce que
commissaire européen il prête serment je
le dire ceux qui nous écoutent qu'ils ne
savent peut-être pas première chose
qu'on fait on prête serment ce qui est
inhabituel pour un homme politique
français devant la cour justice en
séance plénière solennelle d'être
indépendant des intérêts privés ce qui
est la moindre des choses et des
intérêts nationaux dont je suis pas de
représentant de la france je participe
avec mes collègues à la construction d'
intérêt général européen mais j'ai aussi
un devoir que j'assume par exemple on
répondra à vos questions d'explication
dans mon pays dans ma langue aujourd'hui
je peux je pense que c'est aussi ça on
attend deux commissions paix qui sera
patriote et européen oui dont vous allez
panneaux cité deux noms celui qui serait
le mieux placé
on se souvient ainsi dénoncé le choix du
présent la république le moment venu je
recommande qu'on respecte ce choix et
nous on respecte sa décision mais ce que
vous craignez par exemple que cette
nomination dépendent d'un choix
politique trop nationale peut-être
il ya toujours un aspect politique mais
moi je fais confiance au présent
république comme j'ai pu faire confiance
à nicolas sarkozy quand il va proposer
ou à jacques chirac puisque j'ai déjà
été comme il comme son européen en
accord d'ailleurs entre jacques chirac
et lionel jospin à l'époque nous étions
deux commissaires français pascal lamy
est mois pour faire un choix qui soit
conforme à la vision française de
l'europe tout ça dont il s'agit est là
l'intérêt de l'europe donc vous l'avez
dit vous êtes commissaire européen
encore jusqu'à jusqu'à l'automne
prochain et après est ce que vous avez
envie de renouer avec la politique
nationale et après si je suis dans la
commission j'ai pas du tout la scène on
y revient alors reviendrait dans mon
pays qu'il reste pas seulement le mien
que j'avais et je reverrai sans doute
sur le terrain parce que moi j'ai besoin
de la confiance des gens j'ai besoin de
vérifier le soutien populaire voilà ce
que je peux dire alors bien sûr on la
joue rhône alpes qui est ma région là où
j'ai mes racines il prétend dire ça très
vite j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de temps de
toute façon à la carte du moment d'un
pour aller à la rencontre des gens pour
les écouter pour pour pour reprendre
contact quand je vais prendre ce temps
et je demande s'est jamais présenté
j'annoncerai les choses quand j'aurai
pris ce temps de la consultation de la
concertation il dit quand même que
effectivement c'était changerait cette
échéance et régionales jean salem il a
vraiment le dire je garde comme jeu
quand j'avais 22 ans le jour de ma
première élection au suffrage universel
comme conseil général de bourg saint
maurice en haute tarentaise jegun
exactement la même capacité d'
enthousiasme et la capacité
d'indignation qui devrait être celle de
tout homme politique tant que j'ai ça je
re je veux rester dans le débat
politique j'ai peut-être les choses à
apporter y compris par rapport à ce que
j'ai appris ou compris de des enjeux
européens et mondiaux et donc je vais
participer à ce débat et je viendrai
chercher la confiance des gens voilà
vous l'annoncer vous irez chercher la
confiance à nos appels sollicité le
suffrage des électeurs la confiance et
la confiance
rapprocher la région rhône alpes et
l'auvergne ça vous semble une bonne idée
je viens de comprendre qu'il est logique
de tout ça je connais bien l'auvergne
j'ai beaucoup travaillé que les gens
d'ouvert notamment de la révision de la
politique agricole commune pour cette
politique plus juste à l'égard des
éleveurs et qu'elle soit mieux comprise
par tout le monde c'est une grande
région j'ai besoin de comprendre la
logique est quelque part dans cette
réforme que je trouve dutil danse dans
son objectif de réduire nombre des
régions de réduire les frais de
fonctionnement dans ce sens deux villes
d'europe blue qui clament leur âme aux
îles ailleurs on peut le critiquer
critiquer là dessus on les en cas
d'affaiblissement des nations avec ses
grandes roues
quelque part là la réforme qui était
précédé présenté par le présent
gouvernement consistait à prendre les
choses dans l'autre sens a fusionné
progressivement les cons c'est géraud
avec les régions sans changer la taille
des régions j'ai besoin de comprendre où
va se trouver le lieu de solidarité
territoriale parce que les régions
rurales et même parfois les gens obèses
ont besoin d'un endroit de solidarité
qui était celui du conseil général si on
doit supprimer un jour le conseil
général dans de très grandes régions
j'ai peur qu'il manque quelque chose au
milieu pour pour cette solidarité donc
voilà mais je vais essayer de comprendre
la logique de ce rapprochement et
comment comment de tels grande région
peuvent être aussi utile à la solidarité
des territoires michel vagnoux avait été
très critique contre la campagne
européenne de l'ump depuis il ya eu la
ferme bygmalion il ya eu la démission de
tous les partis dont
deux filles il ya eu dans ma propre
famille des des opinions diverses émises
au nom d'un campagne titulaire oui
bonjour françois copé avait exprimé une
ligne a été celle d'alain lamassoure de
tous les candidats dans les territoires
mais mais quelque part il ya eu pas mal
de perturbations et d'henri guaino
division et je pense que c'est le moment
dans la difficulté se trouve l'ump de
privilégier après la sérénité qui doit
revenir de privilégier le débat d'idées
par rapport à d'autres personnes mais
alors qui justement pour incarner ce
débat d'idées qui pour rassurer apaiser
au sein de l'ump est ce que c'est
nicolas sarkozy qui va pouvoir sauver le
parti si ce groupe est très menacée et
lui qui veut dire à ce à quoi il est
prêt j'ai été son ministre je le connais
bien je pense depuis longtemps que son
énergie son expérience sont utiles à la
france et devront être utile ça
maintenant maintenant c'est le moment
n'est pas venu de cela le moment est
venu après cette crise très grave qui
s'ajoute à la division dans le débat
entre jean françois copé et françois
fillon on n'était pas encore sortie de
cette crise là mettait encore
convalescents que le jeu fait confiance
au premier ministre personnellement qui
ont pris le chemin et rires oui françois
à 28 rafale français alain juppé que je
connais bien j'ai été leur ministre les
trois je les respecte beaucoup et s'ils
se mettent ensemble c'est que la
situation est sérieuse et moi je leur
fais confiance pour ramener les
conditions débat d'idées et des
conditions de la confiance qui passe pas
de la transparence visiblement nicolas
sarkozy est quand même très envie
d'entrer là dans le jeu de l'ump est ce
qui reste quand même le meilleur profil
pour votre famille politique en tout cas
celui qui pourrait rassembler notamment
les militants qui sont très déboussolé
je ne sais pas ce qu'il décidera je vous
ai dit personnellement que je reste
proche de lui son expérience et son
énergie je le pense depuis le mois de
mai 2012 reste utile à la france je
pense que l'ump a besoin maintenant de
se reconstruire accrocher les bases de
la confiance et que ça passe d'abord par
le débat presque idéologique qu'elle ait
une politique quel projet d'alternance
quelle est la place de vous parler de
l'europe jeunes à la france veut jouer
en europe quel projet européen pour la
france mais bon ça me paraît être plus
important que le débat de personnes et
vous ne craignez pas du coup la
multiplication des candidatures et du
coup la dispersion sur la ligne
politique
si on a beaucoup de profils qui se
présente du lavoir pour la présidence de
l'ue d'avoir des ambitions beaucoup
mangé une ambition alex devrait pas
aller tout seul
tu peux avoir beaucoup de dignité
beaucoup d'ambition ça n'empêche pas les
gens à nouveau qu'il y ait des ambitions
des la diversité que ces gens se mettent
autour d'une table et moi je voudrais
être tout ça tape ont parlé du projet
politique saissac attendent les champs
kekel ligne politique quels projets quel
changement voilà vraiment vous demandez
à tous les ambitieux de la mettre en
veilleuse
j'ai préféré qu'on privilégie le débat
d'idées sur le débat depuis cinq ans une
question juste sur le député européen
jérôme lavrilleux puisqu'il a reconnu
avoir tripatouillé les comptes de l'ump
est-ce qu'il doit démissionner de son
mandat
il a été élu à strasbourg il est élu
il est pas condamné pour l'instant donc
je vous avais pas nous faire la même
réponse que pour jean marie le pen
non je vais pas me mettre à la place de
la justice je fais très attention à la
présomption d'innocence
les gens sont face à leur conscience
classe que je peux dire un petit mot
pour finir sur les mémoires d'hillary
clinton qui sortent cette semaine elle
livre quelques anecdotes sur les grands
de ce monde
portrait elle dit la plupart des
dirigeants étrangers sont plutôt calmes
en privé ils sont en tout cas ils sont
plus calmes en privé qu'en public sous
nicolas sarkozy il est encore plus
théâtral et divertissant vous le
reconnaissez nicolas sarkozy dans ce
portrait quand tu n'as pas lu ce bouquin
d'hillary clinton je vais peut-être là
puisque je vais à washington cette
semaine passée trois jours de travail et
ça ça me fera plaisir de lire ce livre
parce que c'est une femme qui compte et
qui peut compter détient environ
je vais d'ailleurs ses prédécesseurs
alain devred que je connais bien on pas
de la politique américaine qui m'a
toujours passionné sont des mémoires
américaine je ne sais pas qu'elle porte
elle trace de nicolas sarkozy mais si
c'est pour dire qu'il a de l'énergie à
revendre qui est spontané qui dit ce
qu'il pense oui c était là dans les
potins parce que ça veut dire le potard
il va rentrer
aussi merkel angela merkel comme portant
le poids de l'europe sur ses épaules est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
description c'est aussi ce qu'on peut
lui reprocher un gala merkel et moi je
connais bien gala merkel nous avons
d'ailleurs été ministre de
l'environnement même moment en allemagne
et en france il ya quelques années en 94
95 et adjamé recul elle n'a pas envie
d'être seule elle a pas envie d'être
seule même si elle est la puissance de
sa capacité des personnalités politiques
est très forte et la puissance de
l'allemagne dont elle est la chancelière
mais la police allemagne soit seule elle
a promis d'être seul elle attend que
hier jeu collectif c'est toujours
délicat entre 2 par exemple le président
français et le chancelier allemand même
si je pense que c'est ce dialogue
franco-allemand il est plus en plus
nécessaire de moins en moins suffisant
donc ça dépend de nous que ça dépend de
nous que l'allemagne soit solitaire ou
qu'elle soit solidaire ça dépend de nous
et donc il faut être maintenant de faire
des réformes pas renié la mer leur
message et il n'a pas envie d'être elle
n'a besoin ni de sel
merci a bientot
sans doute donc sur le théâtre national
en savoir l'avait laissé entendre merci
car dans quelques temps merci avant sera
tous apparus